[Music]
do you know what a night nanny is they
take care of the baby at night so mom
and dad can get some sleep I don't want
a stranger in my house it's like a
Lifetime movie we're the nanny tries to
kill the family and the mom it survives
and she has to walk with a cane at the
end
get over yourself mom what's wrong with
your body
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm telly I'm here to take care of you
I'm just not used to people doing things
for me
I hold a baby all day and then nighttime
rolls around and I'm supposed to just
switch gears like hello I'm all sexy now
you're empty yeah no you're empty on
this side your 20's are great but then
your thirties come around the corner
like a garbage truck at 5:00 a.m.
girl skill no you know we might look
like we're all better but if you look
close we're covered in concealer
[Music]
you're convinced that your this failure
but you actually made your biggest dream
come true if you want to run off for
something I get that because I want to
do that too sometimes I'm not gonna I'm
here to help you with everything and
can't fix the parts without treating the
whole yeah no one's treated my oh and a
really long time
[Music]
you